today on the matt walsh show rioting
ravages another american city after a
black man was killed by police
yet hundreds of white people have been
killed by cops over the past year
and there has not been one protest or
riot over any of those deaths if you've
noticed
what does that tell us we'll talk about
that also five headlines including the
media already beginning to preemptively
slander the jurors
in the derek shoven case and the
governor of arkansas continues his media
tour
to try and justify his support for child
castration
it's not going well also polls show that
many americans would like the rock
to run for president almost 50 percent
want the rock to run president
why we'll talk about that plus our daily
cancellation and much more today on the
matt walsh show
so the film rewinds itself and replays
again and again
more rioting in an american city on
sunday night this time back in
minneapolis ground zero the place where
our groundhog's day
nightmare began a year ago in a possible
preview of the rioting that will
probably happen
when the derek chovin trial concludes no
matter how it concludes
blm militants smashed police cars
assaulted police officers vandalized
police stations
looted local businesses video footage
shows
the pillagers ransacking shoe stores
auto parts
retailers pharmacies dollar stores even
pizza restaurants a little caesars they
rioted stole some packages of dough i
guess i don't know why
as we've learned in recent months no
ointment can
numb the pain of systemic racism quite
like an armful of stolen merchandise
at least that's what we're supposed to
believe now the thing that caused
the latest round of rioting is as always
the depravity and moral degeneracy of
the rioters themselves
that's really what causes it but the
ostensible excuse the cover
for the chaos is the death of a man
named dante wright
who was shot and killed by brooklyn
center police during a traffic stop
earlier in the afternoon brooklyn center
is a
town i think to the north of minneapolis
nearby
not many details are currently available
about this incident and as of yet the
body cam footage
has not been released the details don't
matter anyway right they never do blm
has its narrative which is always the
same narrative
and is adjusted only to include the few
sketchy and superficial details
that get imprinted immediately onto the
public
conscious right um in this case
the detail is that wright was pulled
over allegedly
for an air freshener now to hear people
on twitter tell it
and i have and i have seen it phrased
exactly this way
wright was shot by the cops for having
an air freshener
they pulled him out of the car executed
him on the spot
for the air freshener but really because
they're racist
this is the narrative doesn't matter if
it's true or not
and incidentally it is almost certainly
not true as any rational person would
immediately suspect
doesn't mean the shooting was justified
but any person with a brain knows when
they hear that story
there's got to be more to it right based
on the few seemingly reliable details
that have been provided
wright was initially pulled over for a
traffic violation maybe it was the
air freshener it doesn't really matter
but then it was discovered
that he had an outstanding warrant
officers
officers tried to apprehend him but he
ran back to his vehicle
he was shot at some point during that
process he drove away
and crashed shortly after as journalist
andy noe reports
wright had previously posted many
pictures on social media of himself
flashing gang signs using drugs and so
on
now none of this makes the shooting
justified
but it does point to there being more to
the story than just an innocent guy with
an air freshener
there's always more to the story of
course
it's possible that the shooting was
still unjustified that he was murdered
that it's all as bad or nearly as bad as
blm says it is
but if that's the case it will be by
mere happenstance
blm will automatically claim that every
shooting of a black man
by police is a racist execution
perhaps one of these days they'll
accidentally be right
i mean they haven't been right even once
so far about everything
when you take any individual incident
all the things that blm says about that
incident they've never been right about
all of those things
and in terms of of the most basic claim
of a cop shooting a black man because of
racism
they have literally never been right
about that
that has never turned out to be true not
once
maybe this will be the one occasion
where they're right i doubt whether
this is such an occasion but i'll wait
for time and evidence to tell the whole
story
whatever really happened with dante
wright what we can say for sure is that
the average blm or antifa radical out in
the streets
protesting doesn't care what really
happened with dante wright
even less do they care about police
brutality or fascism
least of all do they feel any actual
pain over the loss of life
the anger is performance the tears are
for show because this is all one big
stage play when they're out in the
street crying because of dante wright i
don't believe the tears and you
shouldn't either
the only thing that's real is the
physical destruction they cause
everything else is fake now if that
seems like a harsh assessment
consider the fact that between january
1st 2020
and march 31st 2021 over these past 15
or 16 months
when rioting over alleged police
brutality has been so on trend
there have been 507 white people shot to
death by police
compared to 271 black people and yet
somehow
nobody knows the name of any of those
white people save one ashley babbitt
she was an unarmed woman shot in the
neck and killed by capitol police on
january 6th
we know her name not because blm rallied
to her cause
but because they so conspicuously
refused to rally to her cause
indeed her death was more likely to be
celebrated by the very people
who'd spent the previous year pretending
to care about the killing of unarmed
civilians
anytime you see someone with blm in
their in their their twitter profile
um and they're lamenting the the the
death of dante wright or george floyd or
anyone else
search their name and then the name
ashley babbitt
and see what they had to say about her
because i will tell you right now it's
either
nothing or they were celebrating it
aside from babbitt the names of the
other white people killed by police
are known only to their families and
friends
not one protest has been staged on their
behalf
not one riot has broken out not one
building burned
burned in their honor not one pair of
shoes looted from a foot locker
you know it's a curious thing that those
who are still overwhelmed by the pain of
george floyd's death a year later
they haven't gotten over it there's
overwhelm they didn't know him they
know anything about him they're
overwhelmed by the pain
it's curious they can be so selective in
that pain
was floyd more deserving of mourning was
dante wright more deserving of mourning
than any average white person killed by
the cops
now the excuse most commonly given for
this disparity in coverage and outrage
is that
while black people are killed by police
less often um
when you account for population
disparities they are still more likely
to be killed by police and i've
addressed this claim many times
now even if this statistic needed no
qualification
how does that explain or justify the
fact that people who protest alleged
police brutality
never protest alleged police brutality
against white people
the fact that it happens proportionally
less often
what that means that it's not an outrage
it's not a tragedy
the flag the fact that black people are
more likely to be killed by police means
that
george floyd's death warrants a year of
public wailing in mourning
and the death of a white man warrants no
public wailing or morning
at all okay because the proportionality
of outrage
is is there's zero percent you want to
talk about percentages
there's a smaller percentage of white
people killed by cops
okay but the percentage of outrage
over those killings is zero zero percent
it appears that the black lives matter
crowd really does believe that only
black lives matter
or at least that they matter quite a bit
more than white lives
what other conclusion could one draw
now as it happens the statistics cited
earlier does require qualification yes a
black person is more likely to be killed
by police
but a black person is also more likely
to commit violent crime
if we're talking about proportionality
we have to look at the whole picture
the whole picture even after just a
glance
severely complicates the simplified
racial narrative that you hear from the
blm set
but again this is beside the present
point
that doesn't even matter for the point
that i'm making here
no statistic can explain why the
emotional reaction from the so-called
anti-fascists
should be so selective why they should
remain sitting on their hands while
white people are shot dead waiting until
someone with a darker skin tone suffers
that same fate
real moral outrage doesn't work like
that
and that's how we know that none of the
outrage we're seeing
is real none of it is real
it is all performance it is all fake
it is ideological
really when it comes down to it and we
should always remember that especially
in the months ahead
because there's going to be a lot more
of this a lot more
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
quick word from our good friends at
constitutioncoach.com listen first of
all
it is uh what is it april 12th so you
got just a couple of weeks left
to sign up for constitution coach and
their their class on april 25th
so you want to do that right after i'm
done talking make sure you do that
because my friends over
constitutioncoach.com have a lot of
great programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty by studying
and living out the constitution i've
experienced their constitutional defense
course myself i can
wholeheartedly recommend it and i i just
take my word on it and go do it you
won't rec you won't
regret it believe me you get an amazing
combination of intellectual ammunition
and live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and then
you also get the
physical training at the premier
firearms training facility in the nation
you get all this in the same course
you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation for a
time of learning training
fellowship with like-minded people and
that's a really important part of this
as well
and these look i i went to a whole new
skill level
through this they'll do the same for you
no matter where you're starting from it
doesn't matter
so don't just get a gun learn how to
carry with confidence and get the
training you need at
constitutioncoach.com rick and the
constitution coach team have another
class on april 25th
it'll fill up fast so go now to
constitutioncoach.com
okay well speaking of writing to come
it's already
started well the writing has already
started but
something else that's already started is
is uh the the attacking of the jurors
in the derek shoving case now we know
you know if derek chovin is acquitted
or if he's if he's found guilty on a
lesser charge um
what's going to happen right away is
that we're going to get the media and
the left attacking the jurors and
accusing them all of being racist
you know even though there's i don't i
don't know top of my head what the
racial configuration of the jury is
we can certainly assume that there are
black and whites
on the jury but they're all going to be
racist they're all tools of white
supremacy if he's acquitted or or found
guilty on a lesser charge
um the only maybe surprise here is that
that you would have thought they'd wait
until the verdict
is read before they start this process
but they're not
so i guess at msnbc already attacking
the jurors in the shelving case
let's listen to that but then we have to
think about the juror
and you have to remember this jury has
been seated with
ignorance it's been seated with people
who either
did not see the video which is almost
impossible to do in this country
or saw the video and couldn't decide if
sometimes
maybe black people do need to be choked
to death for eight minutes and 46
seconds
maybe they had it coming so those are
the people that we're talking to here
it's not talking to me it's not trying
to convince you
that that [ __ ] sailed long ago right
they're trying to convince 12 people
that have been
picked specifically for not knowing
things
and so that's what that's what frightens
me no they don't need to put chauvin on
the stand they need
one juror to refuse to see
reason what frightens him
he's just discovered how juries work he
never knew how jerry's this guy i don't
know
you know what this guy's name is um
we'll just we'll just
for simple simple you know to make it
simple we'll just call him a [ __ ]
because that's what he is so this [ __ ]
has just discovered how
juries work in the united states that's
what
that's what frightens him what frightens
him is that the jury is objective
you know what scares me if they're going
to be objective you know what really
frightens me in this case is that the
juror
the jury um didn't go into this with a
verdict already in mind
they didn't go into this with
preconceived assumptions
and by the way they probably did okay um
we can't really know what's going on
inside their minds
but here here's what he is worried
that the jury selection process may have
worked exactly as it's supposed to work
now if you care about things like
justice and truth and
you know the the rule of law uh which of
course nobody on msnbc does but if you
do
then your concern about jury selection
in any case is the opposite of that
what you're worried about is that there
are people who slip through the cracks
who already made up their mind before
going in and there's no way to
you can go through the whole process of
jury selection you're going to end up
especially with a high profile case you
could very easily end up with people
like that the whole jury could be people
have already made up their mind how do
you know
can't know for sure but that should be
the worry
he's concerned that they might be
ignorant about the case going in yeah
[ __ ] that's exactly how it's supposed
to work
you want to find people who never heard
of the case and then
the the first time they're hearing about
it is when they're hearing both sides
presented
in a court of law it's very difficult to
find those kinds of people especially
with a case like this but that's what
you're supposed to look for
this is just like this is as dumb
as who was it chelsea handler who
sent out a tweet a few weeks ago saying
that it's outrageous
that we would be giving derek chovin a
trial when we all saw the crime on video
what kind of country is this where we
give a man a trial
what kind of country is it where we
can't just take him out back and um you
know
put one in his head behind the shed
somewhere
she she was she was outraged by the
simple fact of someone receiving a trial
in front of a jury of their peers and
he's outraged by the same thing
this is just i mean we can laugh about
it because it's so stupid
you know maybe i should i should pause
and step step back
um and even apologize i've been calling
him a [ __ ] this whole time and i
shouldn't be saying that
because that lets him off the hook you
know to call him a [ __ ] or chelsea
hamlet well chelsea handler probably
really is just a more
um but [ __ ] lets them off the hook
they know better this is evil this is an
evil person
you just heard there he obviously knows
how juries work and that is how a jury
is supposed to work
but he is setting up ahead of time to
try to ruin these people's lives if they
don't
come to the verdict that that you know
he
arrived at a verdict in his head a
second after seeing the video
didn't need any additional information
nothing he already decided
in fact he
decided the verdict on the george floyd
case
before it even happened
okay he had decided that morning
when george floyd was still alive and
walking around he had decided a year
before that
okay he because he's already decided
that if a white police officer kills
black men it is racism
period he's already decided that
and he wants jurors who have the same
delusion that he does
absolutely contemptible it really is
because think i mean these jurors
man you talk about a lose-lose situation
you know and and their whole lives at
the
after this probably gonna be ruined
because of guys like that
all right let's move on number two okay
i wanted to play this um
so we have another alleged police
brutality video that that went
viral and a lawsuit has been filed by
the alleged victim
lieutenant karen rosario of virginia
he's a army
lieutenant he obviously didn't die hence
he you know filed a lawsuit personally
but he was pepper sprayed and taken to
the ground
during a traffic stop recently the full
video is several minutes long we can't
play
the whole thing but um as always we'll
play part of it as always the video
fails to show what led up to this um
but here's the part or part of the part
that we are able to see let's watch
what's going on is you fixing to ride
the lightning son
get out of the car now get out of the
car
now get out of the car sir just get out
the car
work with us and we'll talk to you get
out the car you received an order obey
it
i'm i'm i'm honestly afraid to get out
get out of here
you should be get out you got his hands
out the window but he's not he's not
getting out of the car no i have not
committed any crimes
you're being stopped for a tribal
violation you're not cooperating at this
point right now
you're under arrest for you're being
detained okay you're being detained for
obstructive justice
violation i do not have to get out you
haven't even told me
stop really
get out of the car now sir look i'm
trying to get out
okay i'm trying to i'm gonna call get
out the car can you please relax
get out he's relaxed get out of the car
right now
now that's not how you treat a vet uh
i'm actively serving this country and
this is how you're gonna treat me
like i said there's a lot more to the to
the uh the video than that but you know
that's
uh as much as we can play on the show so
the
officer there that that pepper sprayed
um lieutenant
rosario has been fired um
and already you could now you watch
video like that
especially just the clip we just played
but even if you watch the entire video
go online and find it
again you don't see what leads up to it
so there's still context missing
but that's enough to say okay it appears
the police officers
are number one you got two pro just for
as a non-expert
i'm looking at that my immediate
reaction is uh
officers are being more aggressive than
they need to be and they also seem to be
they're they're kind of contradicting
each other because the one officer is
like reaching his hand in is going to
help the guy get out the other one's
saying no don't reach your hand like
they can't even
they're not exactly on the same page
that's a problem
and the other officer saying stuff like
you know you're fixing to ride the light
lightning sun i mean come on
it's like stuff that you say in an
action movie but you're a police officer
now um a guy named zeke arkham is a
also a police officer and a black man
and uh
he chimed in on this case and i thought
what he had to say
was this is always so incredible when
you on the rare occasion when you get to
hear something like this
because here is someone offering their
perspective on a
alleged police brutality incident and
it's a
balanced reasonable non-emotional
perspective
and i really appreciated it for that
reason let's listen to what he has to
say
what went wrong wrong was that the cops
should not have given
conflicting orders usually before you go
on patrol you just you establish
who the communication officer is and the
other guy just kind of stands there
looking good
during the whole car stop or whatever
has to go on usually
the better talker of the two is a
communication officer
what else went wrong uh from what i
understand lieutenant
drove for a mile uh after he was stopped
after the cops initial to him that he
needed him to pull over to the side of
the road
that's not good that now makes the cops
think that something is wrong
and they're going to treat this now as a
felony cost obviously which is what you
saw
on the tape or the video um
what else went wrong once you're pulled
over especially like that
all you do is follow instructions now if
the cops say put your hands outside the
window you put your hands outside the
window
if the cops say exit the vehicle you
reach outside
uh grab your door handle and you exit
the vehicle that way
okay your seat belt should already be
off but if it's not you ask
can i take my seat belt off i have my
seat belt on
okay um after that that after that
you do what the cops say it's not the
time to now start asking
questions and demanding answers that's
not what you should be doing especially
after driving an hour
when after the cops put their lights on
that's not good
okay what went wrong the cop at the end
should not have said don't report this
because now it makes you seem like
you're doing something wrong
so i mean there was wrong on both parts
but there was more wrong one
lieutenant's part
who thought that it was now his place to
start checking the cops
amazing so it is just a
looking at the situation uh
no no bias going into it wrong on both
ends
a balanced sensible
reasonable now uh
this man who's his name he had zeke
arkham he he knows more about
police procedure than i do certainly uh
but even from my perspective it makes a
lot of sense what he had to say makes a
lot of sense
it's just it's so refreshing because you
rarely hear that anymore
about these kinds of incidents
and because what happens is something
like this occurs
and you have to immediately we stuff it
into a certain narrative
and it's it can't we can never have you
know
something happens and it just happened
and that's it and it's a it's a it's an
isolated incident
and uh you know you come to any
conclusion you want to and then you move
on
we can't do that anymore everything that
happens
especially if it's on camera and it
involves police and a black man
everything that happens it's it is a
it's a national crisis
it's a symptom of some great um
you know some deep-seated problem
and also you have to put all the blame
on
one side or the other
and and usually taking police out of it
for a second
in in in in most human interactions
that turn hostile
most of the time there's gonna be some
amount of blame on both sides
most of the time it takes two to tango
it doesn't again doesn't matter if it's
police involves the police or not
if you're watching a video where
interaction between two people
escalates in this way
most of the time it's not going to be
only one party
that is fully responsible
so i think that seems pretty reasonable
and by the way something
not totally dissimilar to this actually
has happened to me i wasn't pepper
sprayed by the police
but years ago when i think i was
probably 19 or 20 years old
i was driving along a residential
neighborhood
um i was getting pulled over for
speeding and i was speeding i hate to
admit
and uh the the cop you know they put the
lights on and i
it seemed to me okay we're on a
residential road there's there's not a
there's not much of a shoulder here
and i knew because i knew the road i
knew that like a mile or two up
there was a place where i could safely
pull in and so i made this the stupid
decision to keep on driving until i got
to that spot
and uh of course the cops are now
thinking why isn't this guy pulled over
just like we just heard in the video
there
cause cop is thinking okay he's not
pulling over something is wrong he's
gonna try to run away he's got drugs in
the car he's stashing he's doing
something
finally i pull over and the cop rolls up
and he's got another cop car coming
behind him i guess he radioed for
somebody
and they pulled me out of the car and it
was a it was a
pretty scary situation for a few minutes
because they didn't understand why i
wasn't pulling over
but as soon as they got out of the car
and told me to get out of the car i did
and i
listened and then i was able to go home
with just a speeding ticket and i wasn't
pepper sprayed
all right um
okay let's move on to this asa
hutchinson appeared on
state of the union to defend his
pro-child castration
position now already
he you know we know he was on tucker
carlson last week and that did not go
well for him at all
and of course it's not going to go well
for him he is again defending an
indefensible position
there is nothing that you can say in
defense of it that will sound reasonable
or moral but he
can't get enough of it so here he is on
cable news again defending the same
position
and he comes across as bad as he did
before let's listen
anytime you go against the grain you're
going to get that kind of blow back i
think it's healthy
for our society i think it's helpful for
our party to have that kind of vigorous
debate
about an important issue and to me
this is about the future of our party
are we going to be a narrow party
that expresses ourself in intolerant
ways
are we going to be a broad-based party
that shows
conservative principles but also
compassion in dealing with some of the
most difficult issues that parents face
that individuals face and at some point
i had to say i've got to remind
my wonderful republican colleagues that
we are the party of ronald reagan that
believes in a limited role of government
and let's just ask that question
sure i'm i sign pro-life bills and i
know that there's a role for government
even in the social issues but we have to
fundamentally ask ourselves
do we need to do this is there a better
way is this something that we need to
leave to the hand
in the home or in the church our faith
leaders to handle
is this calling out for a government
solution we're fighting that in
washington
uh let's fight it also in our state
capitals and within the
and fight for the principles of our
party what a sniveling repugnant snake
this guy is
yeah you're talking about compassion the
only
person he has compassion for this is
this is not compassion at all this is
him
being a [ __ ] for his corporate pimps
that's what this really is
walmart someone told him to take this
position that's why he's taking it and
now he's uh
framing it as compassion
let me be the first to say asa
that uh yeah i i am fully intolerant
of the castration of children i'm
intolerant of
all forms of child abuse and um
would be it physical abuse psychological
emotional
and the thing is what we're doing with
kids with the gender stuff that is
all forms of abuse of abuse rolled into
one it's physical sexual
emotional and psychological abuse all
rolled into one horrifying package
and yeah i'm intolerant of all of that
deeply intolerant of it
there's certainly a place for
intolerance and that's the place
if there's if there's ever an occasion
for the government to intervene
it would be with something like this
and by the way i don't care when it
comes to the abuse of children
what i don't care if the parents are
often times when a child is being abused
the parent is okay with the abuse
because the parent is the one
um doing the abuse
does that make it more acceptable does
that mean we should butt out and mind
our own business
and if the doctors are involved in the
abuse doesn't make a difference to me
only in the case it only makes a
difference in the sense that it makes
the abuse so much worse
and it gives us so much more cause for
the government to get involved
but i'm explaining all this and asa
hutchinson obviously knows that
there's a reason why this guy at the age
of 70 has been in public life forever
like all these people have
and he has as far as i know
70 years of life he has
never once um spoken out in favor of
child castration until this past week
never indicated that he's in favor of it
never indicated his belief that you know
a a boy can have a little girl trapped
inside him and the only way to
set that inner girl free is to castrate
the boy he
he 70 years of life he never
indicated that he that he believes that
this is a sudden conversion experience
his road to damascus moment
that he that he's experienced
and we know that it's not because of
self-reflection and prayer
unless he's praying to satan i don't
know um number five this is from the new
york post that says at least 46
of americans want to see dwayne the rock
johnson run for president
a new poll is found more than thirty
thousand people were surveyed by
pip pipple say for their take on
celebrities including johnson and
matthew mcconaughey who may be
interested in politics 29
said they want to see both mcconaughey
and johnson who are eyeing runs for
texas governor u.s president
respectively
run for office now okay 46 want to see
the rock run that doesn't mean that 46
said they'd vote for him they just want
to see him run
if i want to take the most optimistic
interpretation of this poll
maybe it's that people figure it'd be
entertaining to have a guy like the rock
run for president
and although they wouldn't really vote
for him they'd like to see him in the
mix
for entertainment purposes
even that i don't think it's very
justified because i i think we need to
get away from
seeing politics as a a form of
recreation and entertainment
and actually approach the issue like
adults
i know i know we're way past that so
we're at a point now
where um
you probably need joe biden may be
the last guy to be elected president who
does not have the celebrity factor
we're probably at a point now where
you're not going to win unless you have
the celebrity factor so
he i i think the rock could win
assuming he runs it as a democrat which
i guess he would oh he certainly would
run as a democrat um obviously all the
leftists are going to vote for him
because he's running as a democrat
could he siphon enough so-called
conservatives
who buy his whole shtick on instagram
and everything and his public persona
probably yeah um finally i want to play
this just a little bonus content
brian stelter on cnn
now i never watch his show but um every
time i see a clip of his show
on online all he's ever doing is talking
about fox news
so i and i say this this is a sincere
question
does he report on anything but what fox
news personalities are doing
he is like he's like the tmz for fox
news personalities he's like the
paparazzi for tucker carlson
and the rest of the bunch and so here he
is um taking
issue with fox news personalities for an
especially stupid reason let's listen
it's really important to see all these
tv anchors personalities
showing themselves getting the shot
we've seen a lot of vaccine selfies
from lots of folks at lots of different
networks uh it's been really inspiring
to see
you know the today show even brought the
the co-host outside
for a live group vaccination this week
and rachel maddow on friday on msnbc
talked about how
she was really fearful of the needle
really worried about it
and yet it was important to get the shot
and she did and there she is talking
about it on air
so i say all of that to make the
following point
where are tucker and sean hannity and
laura ingram where is ainsley earhart
and steve ducey and brian kilmeade
where are the biggest stars on fox
getting vaccinated
i get it's a personal choice i get
that's between you know
the hosts and their healthcare provider
but everybody else is doing it right
matt i mean all across television all
these anchors
are rolling up their sleeves why do you
think we haven't seen the biggest stars
on fox news
get vaccinated or show us their vaccine
selfies
roll up your sleeves and take those
selfies all right let's get down to
business let's get down to work
roll up the sleeves let's take some
selfies all right that's your response
but
i get i understand it's a personal
choice but
i am outraged that you have not taken a
picture of yourself
um taking advantage of this personal
choice and post it post it online i'm
outraged by that
it's a personal choice between you and
your healthcare provider but i demand to
see pictures
okay calm down you weirdo
he's he's actually angry
that he hasn't seen a picture of tucker
carlson getting a shot
there's some kind of weird fetish on his
end i don't i don't
understand it at all but you see that um
right there the screenshot fox's biggest
stars have not shared vaccine selfies i
swear to you
when i saw that screenshot online i
thought it was a joke i really did
i'm still i i can't help it i'm an
optimist when it comes down to it
i saw that screenshot i thought no come
on
they haven't gotten that stupid over
there have they no nope
my optimism misleads me yet again
story of my life all right let's move on
to reading the comments um first comment
says teens themselves have been trying
to get james charles d-platform for
months now
but tick-tock and other companies
backing him are actually deleting the
post showing proof of his behavior
thanks for blasting this out for more
people to see i got a lot of comments
like those and messages too from
people saying that a lot of teenagers in
james charles's audience
have been the ones calling attention to
his alleged alleged preying on
underage boys in this case you have the
big corporations like tick tock and
youtube and his corporate sponsors
that are keeping him platformed
in spite of that this is one case where
a d
platforming campaign is wholly justified
and needed
there's a lot of very good evidence
including james charles
as we played on friday his own words
confessing for example that he's tried
to fly
high school boys out to meet him
presumably for sex
so there's a lot of that kind of thing
very good evidence that he is someone
who's at least attempting to prey on
underage boys yeah
deplatform someone for that yes
absolutely
do you platform someone for sharing
controversial opinions
no but if they're using their platform
allegedly to prey on
children yeah definitely
but of course in our backwards world
it's the opposite is how it works
you get the platform for the
controversial opinions but if all you're
doing is preying on
underage children then you can keep your
platform all right
this is from s williams says no adult
who has ever used the phrase that's
trigger that's triggering unironically
should be taken seriously for another
moment in their entire life
um yeah well of course
along with any adult that uses the word
uh lived experience i mean there are a
lot of
phrases and a lot of opinions frankly
that someone can share that
although they have the right to share
them means that i personally can never
take them seriously again
bex mckay says matt's plan with the
shirt is to wear it out of spite until
the haters grow to genuinely love it and
it's already working he's smarter than
us all
and morgan says matt walsh's polka dot
shirt is to julia child's pearls
iconic you should probably invest in a
few more colors matt
well i told you joshua says i'm happy to
see you are indeed a man of your word
and wore your gentleman's blouse again
gentleman's blouse
don't take my laughter as a as me
approving of you
calling my shirt a gentleman's blouse it
is just a shirt
have you people actually never seen
a shirt with dots on it
it's it's i you know i don't do a lot of
clothing shopping which
maybe is is clear but i i i think that
that's a pretty common pattern to see on
clothing even for men
am i wrong in any case i promise i'll
wear it once a week and i will certainly
do that
uh krish the neat says fa'a
fafines are a real thing in samoa and
quite common
it means in the way of the woman i live
there as a kid and will always remember
the huge guy in a moo moo
named rosie he ran the motel where we
were staying
and staying in and dressed like a woman
with makeup and a long braid
he also had a wife and kids
well there you go so what you're saying
there
proves my point that i made on friday
you may have in other cultures
people who break the gender barriers and
so on
uh so-called quote-unquote non-binary
people
but the guy wearing the moo moo named
rosie with a wife and kids
right correct me if i'm wrong he's not
actually claiming that he literally
is a woman he may be
dressing the part but there's no
confusion about what he actually is
biologically
we are we in the west are unique in that
confusion
and that's the point that we were making
you know you could always tell when
someone
didn't get a good night's sleep they got
the bags under the eyes they look
gross and tired i don't know why that
grosses me out but it does
but even worse that you could tell when
someone else to get good night's sleep
but you
when you yourself are experiencing that
it just it could kind of ruin the entire
day
why go through that if you don't have to
and if you get a helix mattress
then that means you don't have to
experience bad sleep ever again helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back no matter how you sleep no
matter what your preferences are
they've got something that is made just
for you you don't need to take their
word for it helix was awarded the number
one
best overall mattress of 2019 and 2020
by gq and wired magazine
just go to helix helix sleep.com walsh
take their two minute sleep quiz i've
taken it myself and then they're going
to send you a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life guaranteed i have
this exactly what my experience was
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
walls that's helix sleep dot com slash
walls for up to 200
off your mattress order well it's
already episode 5 and
we can't get enough of candace owens or
her new show candace if you haven't
checked it out yet
um i don't know what you're waiting for
you got to go do it the fearless thought
leader hosts a lively series of guests
each week for discussion panel
interviews
this week she'll be hosting comedian and
podcaster adam corolla
make sure you tune in you don't want to
miss that the show streams on fridays at
9 pm eastern 8 pm central
dailywire.com but you can get the audio
podcast also candace
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast so if you need some
candace owens in your podcast feed
look no further head over to apple
podcast or spotify and subscribe today
and be sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear
let's get now to our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation on this
monday we revisit the subject of fat
acceptance and body positivity
this is a topic which has popped up
several times during the segment
during this particular segment daily
cancellation you might even say that it
weighs heavily on my mind
what brings it up today are the slew of
articles preemptively condemning
anyone who shames anyone else over their
weight gain during the covet lockdowns
the media is anticipating that millions
of americans are going to emerge from
their cocoons this summer
like bulbous flightless butterflies
their time in lockdown having
transformed them from overweight
to even more overweight but we are
warned
do not shame anyone for this it's not
their fault
the daily beast has an article from
elena um
demopolis that's how you pronounce the
last name it's titled
our bodies emerge from lockdown to a fat
shaming chorus
ignore it and she says quote if you want
to lose the quarantine 15 that's okay
and if you don't or can't that's okay
too
find the best way to exercise that works
for you
later in the article or an especially
revealing passage she quotes amy conway
who's the editor-in-chief of health
magazine
and she says quote a lot of people have
been sedentary and there are concerns
about going back to work
that might feel more winded going up a
flight of stairs
so moving your body throughout the day
is uh certainly something we'll
encourage
it's not about how to lose the
quarantine 15 it's about making people
feel good
that's all that matters slate has a
similar diatribe this one titled
how to survive post-pandemic weight loss
pressure
the article written uh is written by a
rebecca onion
i know i'm not sure why the ladies of
the daily beasts and slate all have
names that sound made up but miss onion
lectures the reader not to post about
their workout routines or or their
weight loss strategies because
then your social media followers who
prefer to be lazy bastards my words not
hers
might feel bad and remember as we learn
from the daily beast this is all about
making people feel good that's all that
matters
by the way if you're wondering the
experts agree which experts
doesn't matter we've learned that too
the experts have spoken doesn't matter
you don't need to know the details but
the experts have said this
the website verywellhealth.com
has this headline quote experts stop
making people feel bad about covid
weight gain
we need the experts to tell us don't
make people feel bad uh this one is
written by carlo delgado who is
at least appears to be a real person
based on her name now i must admit
off the bat that i can't relate to any
of this content
um first of all i've personally been out
of lockdown since march by that i mean
march of 2020
i never really entered into lockdown
except to the extent that i was forced
to
when everything around me shut down but
even when everything was shut down
we were still very active in my family
more active than we'd ever been if
anything because there wasn't much else
to do besides running around outside go
for hikes go for walks and all that kind
of thing
that's why my wife and i both emerge
from this past year in very good
physical shape
now i realized that my bragging about my
own fitness
that by doing that i just did the very
thing that slate and the daily beast
warned me not to do
so why did i do it well because they
told me not to do it
and also because i'm not going to be
made to feel embarrassed and ashamed
of being physically healthy because
that's insane
you know in my life like most people
i've been out of shape and i've been in
shape
and i mean i'm always some kind of shape
just not one that i prefer all the time
and i always felt embarrassed about
being out of shape not about being in
shape
that's how it should be and why is it
because i was out of shape because i was
lazy it's embarrassing to be lazy
a person ought to be embarrassed by that
they shouldn't dwell in that
embarrassment they shouldn't stew in it
wallowing it
i'm not recommending depression and
self-loathing as a strategy i'm
recommending that people simply confront
the reality of their own personal
situation uh
admit that it's not ideal to be
overweight admit that they have control
over it
and then take control and change it
see the problem is that the the body
positivity mentality
precludes people from trying to change
the things they don't like about
themselves
and that fact points to the glaring
self-contradiction in this whole mindset
it's a contradiction that has of course
been evidence been in evidence for for a
long time
long before the pandemic for example
here's a clip from a show on the oprah
winfrey network it was it just went
viral over the past couple weeks
but it originally aired i think in 2019
so here's an overweight woman
explaining how it's not her fault that
she's overweight because racism
did it to her let's watch you can't get
access to good health care good
insurance
the research says that black women when
we do the same diets as white women
we lose less weight and we lose it
slower
even when we're following the diet than
our white women counterparts
and what and what public health
practitioners think is that our stress
responses in the body
change our metabolism it's literally
that
the racism that you're experiencing and
the
struggle to make ends meet actually
means
the diet don't work for you the same
[Applause]
i mean we've made everything else racist
why not make carbs and calories racist
too but whether racism is the lame
excuse for gaining weight or it's the
pandemic
or whatever else we come up with so that
we can avoid going for a jog because
that's really what all this is about
um the whole body positivity movement is
just
one long way around having to go for a
jog
but whatever the excuse is the fact is
that we're making excuses
okay and that's interesting isn't it
because we're we are both
making excuses for weight gain and going
to great lengths to make sure that
people
don't feel bad about their weight gain
and yet at the same time
the body positivity movement tells us
that we should be proud of our bodies
no matter their shape no matter how many
extra pounds of lard maybe drop draped
over them
we should celebrate our fatness not our
fitness
we're told so so then which is it
you know if you ought to be proud of
your fat body then
why are you making excuses for the fact
that it's fat it seems like an oddly
schizophrenic message
if you're declaring well fat is
beautiful i'm so proud of it
and also it isn't my fault that i'm like
this don't blame me
this is a case of having the cake and
eating it too which ironically is also
how you put the extra pounds on
point being you really have to choose
right
either obesity is a disease an
affliction something that has befallen
you by pure happenstance and misfortune
or it's something beautiful and powerful
and worth celebrating
it it can't really be both i mean
let's think of an example we would all
agree that bone cancer for instance
is an affliction a disease a terrible
misfortune but we would also
agree that that we don't call it
beautiful we don't celebrate it
neither would we say that a person with
cancer should be ashamed obviously but
we do recognize it as a bad thing
and something that if we can we want to
stop
get rid of prevent ultimately we want to
cure it cancer is bad
we want to destroy cancer there's no
controversy about that
with obesity there should also be no
controversy it's a bad thing in many
cases it's a fatal thing
we should want to get rid of it
fortunately getting rid of obesity is a
thousand times easier than getting rid
of cancer
all you have to do in the majority of
cases is eat less and exercise more for
almost every overweight person on the
planet and throughout history
in almost every case that is enough to
solve the problem it is a very simple
solution i didn't say an easy solution a
simple one
the only thing that makes obesity
confusing and controversial
is that the body positivity movement
can't figure out its own position on the
subject
they want us to both pity the obese for
their obesity and also celebrate the
obese for their obesity
but you see a trait cannot be both
pitiful and
praiseworthy it can't be a disease and
beautiful what kind of thing is that to
say what is it a beautiful disease
you have to choose between the two it's
either beautiful or it's disease
we should either celebrate it or it's
not your fault it's a terrible thing
that happened to you one or the other
now personally between the two options
um i would hope you choose the woe is me
it's not my fault it's because of racism
it's because of the pandemic approach
well you just heard there in the in the
in the video clip i'd prefer that
go with that because at least then
you're admitting that obesity is a bad
thing
a thing we should want to get rid of not
embrace
that's not much but it's a start we can
work with that
now it's just a matter of getting you to
accept a little bit of personal
accountability
and you can start by being accountable
for the fact that you are
today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show new police incidents
roil the country as riots break out
again in minneapolis
corporate america activates against
everyday americans and the media
continue to promote covid panic porn
that's on today's ben shapiro show give
it a listen